Continuing in
the
18th or 19th book of
offered by
Allahala.
He says,
Fore
[Silence]
collects a narration
and reports on the authority of Mdas
He narrates to us that the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam said
the righteous will continue to become
more and more scarce
and more and more rare.
Each generation
will contain
less than the previous
until what is left of humanity,
meaning in spite of their numbers,
the ratio of righteous
to unrighteous amongst humanity
will be the leftovers. ers in the
bag
after taking out.
you know, if you have a a bag
full of wheat or a bag full of barley or
a bag full of grain and you take out all
of the grain and or if you have a bag
full of
let's say some
dates, right? Well, there's other
things in that bag. It's not just pure
grain. There are the skins of the grain.
There's some of the stems that are in
there. There's some of the grain that
has turned to powder, right? there's
some little branches in there, little
bits of leaves and so forth. Things that
are not something that you would want to
put in your food. It's leftover usually
at the very bottom of the bag. In
America or in the west in English, we
have the same type of
saying where we say the bottom of the
barrel. You've heard this before, right?
That this is this this product or this
person is bottom of the barrel. What
does that mean? bottom of the barrel.
Meaning, if you have a barrel full of
any goods, the weakest, most
the thing that you would throw away, the
thing that no one wants, the thing that
is more of a nuisance than it is
useful is what settles at the bottom of
a barrel. Right? And so the prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam tells us
that the righteous people from amongst
humanity when we say righteous in the
prophet's lingo in his terminology in
the terminology of the Quran and Sunnah
does righteous include
Muslim and non-Muslim
and we say righteous does this mean
righteous from amongst Christianity and
righteous from amongst Juda Judaism and
righteous from amongst Buddhism and
righteous from amongst Hinduism and
righteous from amongst atheism. Is there
any such thing as righteousness
withoutahill?
Linguistically, customarily people may
refer to righteous meaning someone who
has good character or acceptable
character. But that's not what is meant
in the Quran and Sunnah in the language
of the prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam that is the same language as
the Quran and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
right when he speaks about those who are
righteous those who are people of salah
and they are the people of
righteous deeds speaking about those who
have accepted Islam
now there is often a misunderstanding
with respect to this
and that is that a person says, "Well,
what about a Christian or a Jew or a
non-Muslim who's never heard about Islam
before, right?" And they do the best
with what they have.
we say that's all well and good and that
may excuse a person in the hereafter and
that may be something of an excuse
between them and Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala however the characteristic of
Islam and Muslim this is not something
that you can stumble upon it's not
something that you can accidentally just
because you're so good nature be a
Muslim doesn't work that you have
to have guidance happens from the
messenger of Allah Muhammad Sam.
If that were the case, then it would be
enough to just have the fra. We all
agree as human beings that, you know,
stealing is wrong, murder is wrong,
goodness is is good, trustworthiness
is a good trait, dignity is a good
trait, right? then we could just have
that be the yard stick. However, that is
not the case. Righteousness,
this is something that can only come
about by way of knowledge. And if that
person has not received that knowledge,
they have no way to righteousness
without it.
This is not to be confused with someone
who does not have an excuse or someone
that does have an excuse. Someone who
never received that knowledge. Someone
who had no access to that knowledge. The
people of Alat in
right. They may have an excuse. That's
all well and good. But righteousness is
not something that a person naturally
comes about. It's something that can
only be earned and only earned by way of
knowledge, by way of revelation, by way
of guidance by a messenger. This is a
very important point because often times
these two things are conflated and
confused.
The idea of being excused and being
righteous, they are two very different
things, right? someone who is who
does not have the guidance of the Quran,
could they perhaps
obtain
sparse bits of wisdom through life
experience and through
you know the wisdom of of other
people's experience and be naturally
prone to good. , could they not have
elements of wisdom? Yes. Could they not?
Could you not find a an atheist that is
trustworthy? It's possible. Is it
possible to find a Buddhist that is
generous? Yes, it's possible.
And and and not only that, but it
exists, right? Are there not Hindus
which are courageous right who
defend the weak and and and so forth.
Yes, these things are found. But are all
of these traits found in a single person
without the guidance of the Quran? No,
that is not possible. That is not the
case because the light of Allah
that is the light of the Quran and
Sunnah cannot be replicated by humanity.
It has to come from outside of us.
Right? We hear often the believe in
yourself and you know these kinds of
statements. This is a circular argument.
I cannot both I cannot be
knowledgeable and ignorant at the same
time of the exact same things. It's
either day or night, black or white. And
so for the human being, I am either weak
or I I am strong. I can't be weak and
strong simultaneously in the exact same
way. Therefore, if I need something,
it's something that I don't have in
myself. I have to get it from outside of
myself. And so,
this is akin to the paradox of pulling
yourself up by your own bootstraps.
You've ever heard of this before? I want
you to imagine with me someone who grabs
their feet and lifts themsself off of
the ground. Is that possible?
Huh?
Of course it's not possible.
That is that is circular physically. I
have to have something to support myself
on in order to raise myself. Therefore,
the idea that
there are righteous people outside of
the of Islam. This is a fallacy in
itself. There are elements of
righteousness outside of the of
Islam. Sure.
And are there generally
acceptable people outside of Islam?
Yes, of course. But someone to have the
qualities that can only be learned by
way of the Quran and Sunnah, to have
them without having the Quran and
Sunnah, this is an impossibility.
And if we were to say this, that means
that the Quran and Sunnah are redundant.
Humanity already had these traits. We
didn't really need the Quran and Sunnah
to guide us then after all. And so the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam tells us here
that
righteous
people, the righteous
from amongst humanity will continue to
become more and more sparse, more and
more infrequent, less and less every
generation following the next.
until what is left of humanity
is of the quality that is left at the
bottom of the barrel.
That is going to be the the top quality
found in humanity. The prophet
sallall.aii Wasam says
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will have
no
will not entertain them in the least.
He has he has no use for them. This is
not speaking about
before
the
death of Isaam.
This is speaking about after the sun
rises from the west. This is speaking
about after the animal, the creature
appears upon humanity. This is
speaking about after the three major
earthquakes. This is speaking about just
before the day of judgment when Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala takes back the Quran
and then takes back everyone who has in
his heart even a grain's weight or a
seed's weight of faith. And the only
ones that will remain on the earth are
those who are the bottom of the barrel
whom Allah will have no use for. And
upon them the day of judgment will
commence.
[Silence]
forham.
Alhamdulillah.
Thanks. I don't want
you. Have you seen his daughter?
[Silence]
And she's without
Are you ready?
They made it
big.
[Silence]
years.
My oldest
[Silence]
color I said.
Thank you.
How are you?